ça bouge à l'espace régler pendant les
vacances de juillet et août
plusieurs ateliers sont proposés aux
tout petits et aux plus âgés pour avoir
la tête dans les étoiles des ateliers
créatifs autour de l'astronomie le
mercredi 20 juillet le samedi 23 juillet
le mercredi 27 juillet et le samedi 30
juillet de 14h à 16h plusieurs balises
créatifs comme l' origami pour les plus
de 7 ans ou encore la fabrication d'une
boîte à images pour les plus de 8 ans
des ateliers d'illustration avec moniri
m'bae sont aussi programmées pour créer
et réinterpréter des extrait du petit
prince d'antoine de saint-exupéry
rendez vous le mardi 19 juillet le jeudi
21 juillet le vendredi 22 juillet de
15h30 à 17h30 cet atelier est ouvert aux
enfants de plus de six ans et puis pour
ceux qui angoissent déjà l'idée de la
rentrée et plus particulièrement ceux
qui entrent en sixième des ateliers
originaux je prépare ma rentrée en 6e
sont proposés les vendredi 22 et 29
juillet de 15h30 à 17h30 les activités
du coin des enfants continue pendant les
vacances
bibliothèque et ludothèque en accès
libre et les livres c'est bon pour les
bébés vous attendent dans le cadre
magnifique de l'espace régler pour toute
inscription et information en seul
numéro le 06 92 97 40 26 au musée du sel
le sel dans tous ses états ça se passe
dans l'ouest du côté de saint leu
plusieurs ateliers au programme avec
entre autres en selle à votre goût nous
comment tu peux réaliser ton sel épices
et c'est le mercredi 20 juillet de 10
heures à 12 heures et de 14 heures à 16
heures quand le sel se mélange au
chocolat ce sera un atelier gourmand
proposé aux marmailles de 6 à 12 ans
jeudi 28 juillet aux mêmes horaires
il y aura aussi des dessins du modelage
en pâte à sel des comptes en créole le
nar
outre toujours de 10 heures à 12 heures
et de 14 heures à 16 heures pour toute
information et inscription aux ateliers
un numéro le 02 62 34 67 00 parmi les
nombreuses propositions d'animations et
d'ateliers de mascarin jardin botanique
de la réunion nous grimpons demain ou
comment mieux connaître les légumineuses
de la réunion en effet quel est le point
commun entre le tamarin des hauts le col
cole le bois noir et la lentilles de
cilaos
ce sont des légumineuses dont une
catégorie peut être consommée cette
animation s'inscrit dans l'année
internationale des légumineuses pour
tout savoir de ce qui se passe dans les
hauteurs de saint-leu en seul numéro le
02 62 24 92 27 retour à saint-denis
du côté de la rto la création est aussi
à l'honneur
l'artothèque propose des ateliers de
pâte à modeler ou encore des découpages
le papier et collages en août une
fresque sera réalisée à la manière de
fernand léger
il s'agit d'une création à partir de
personnages de couleur prédécoupés pas
de limite d'âge l'atelier se tiendra de
10h à 12h et de 13h30 à 15h30
un numéro de téléphone pour se
renseigner au 02 62 41 75 50 atelier
original et précieux au musée léon dierx
l'aimé 200 $ propose de s'initier à la
restauration de tableaux à partir de ces
temps les enfants pourront aborder la
notion de conservation et de
restauration des oeuvres des
reproductions de tableaux appartenant à
la collection du musée ont été dégradés
et doivent être retouché à la gouache
des vocations naîtront probablement de
ces ateliers
rendez vous du mardi au vendredi de 9h30
à 12h et de 13h30 à 16h il faut réserver
au 02 62 92 45 92 après une flânerie
dans le jardin de l'état pourquoi ne pas
se rendre au muséum d'histoire naturelle
les requins leurs mystères sont toujours
record de l'exposition requins
l'occasion de découvrir le clone du
mythique requin tigre modelé par salim
le taxidermiste du muséum
atelier ou découverte des musées mais
aussi flâner au marché plus longtemps en
compagnie de ses enfants
le guide des sentiers marmaille est pour
vous le conseil départemental a
participé à sa réédition actualisée
vous pouvez le télécharger sur le site
www.sgbourse.fr
sans itinéraire deux heures maximum de
marche des sentiers sécurisé sans
difficulté et avec un dénivellé faible
voilà ce que vous propose ce guide de
l'office national des forêts en
partenariat avec le département
alors que vous soyez plus attiré par
l'art par les activités manuelles ou
encore les randonnées dans les sentiers
de l'île profitez des vacances pour vous
faire la belle et n'hésitez pas à vous
connecter sur le www.cegedim.fr et sur
les sites de nos équipements culturels 3
wcg no 7 4 point fr slash culture bonnes
vacances à tous